bitcoin is on fire it went from nothing
to 34 000
dropped 17 percent everybody panics it's
down to 30 000
but jp morgan chase just predicted it's
pretty crazy for jp morgan chase to say
this by the way jp morgan chase just
said
that bitcoin in 2021
could pass 146 000 yeah
they said it could pass 146 000 in
2021 thoughts on bitcoin offended
someone said the other day
was it the guggenheim uh they they gave
an interview it's a pretty public
um philanthropic investment type asset
uh
financial firm and they said they
thought that bitcoin can go to
uh 500 000 in the next few years so this
kind of goes back to the tesla thing
there's a difference if you're investing
to all our investor friends out there
there's a difference between
day trading and decade trading right so
if you're who knows what's going to
happen to bitcoin like have you freaked
out in 2018 oh it's going down it's
going down
and the high was 20 000. now we're
talking about oh my god it might come
down from 30 000.
the the the big question is where will
tesla be in five to ten years where will
bitcoin be in five to ten years
long term if you're thinking you know
shorting and it's going to be short in
the next year or so whatever
who freaking knows that's not the point
of investing it's a long-term strategy
yeah that's
sort of the problem that people get in
is they try to time the market it's not
about
timing the market it's about time in the
market right so
i think for a few years people were not
trusting crypto not trusting
um bitcoin not trusting um
blockchain everything but clearly with
everyone coming out there
you just said jp morgan you had who
paypal you had visa you have all these
financial firms they're saying yeah
we're in on this we're in so the
question is is there a chance that it
goes to zero or it goes to a hundred
thousand what
zero no that's my okay so that's my
question there's more of a likely of a
chance in the next few years it goes to
a hundred thousand to zero
i agree okay i don't disagree so yeah
that's what i'm thinking long term
yep i think if you like did adam's
theory where he you know asked these
girls randomly on the streets in miami
do you want a rich guy or a if you asked
randomly it's not random but i guess
girls i know but yeah okay don't you
think 99.9 percent of people don't know
what the hell bitcoin is
yeah so i correct i think this is a this
is a game
for people that understand it they will
doctor this price however they see
fit for them and i think there's no
limit to how high it can get
and i just don't think anybody
understands it last week there was a
pretty big story because the first
professional athlete is having part of
his salary in bitcoin an offensive
lineman and i forgot who he plays for
now he used to play for seattle
which is fascinating now he is sponsored
by a bitcoin company so him
sending out tweets you know he's having
to do that and i i didn't really fully
understand
just how much he knew about it other
than he was promoting the company but
i think you're going to see a lot more
of this i think people that want to
act like they're a step ahead you know i
just don't think there's a full
understanding
of the average american what bitcoin is
let me let me give you uh
just a different perspective on what
happened on december 31st with me
december 31st
i have a million things to do and i'm
trying to finish off my year but at the
same time
i'm trying to get my dividends paid out
to all the investors okay
so i call chase i'm on the phone 30
minutes with chase on the phone their
phone system wasn't working first call
hangs up i call chase again it hangs up
i call chase
it's seven times after being on hold for
15 minutes chase things up
then i have different then i start
calling on three different phones then i
get my
relationship manager then i go then i go
to chase directly then i
it the whole event took about four hours
of my day
i sent a tweet to chase chase responds
back i said it's your phone system down
not working i'm speaking with your
seventh rep now
and your whole music works but the rep
speaks they cut out our finance
department has had problems with your
phones all day
they tried on three landlines and two
cell phones and nothing
one guy responds back to me and he says
if you have to ask permission to use
your money
then it's not really yours and he says
bitcoin can fix this
right so he says this and i sit and i'm
like you know what
the fact that it took four hours of my
day
that i have to go do all of this stuff
are you really patrick bet david
what the hell do i have to tell you if
i'm patrick david so i'm sitting like
you know what
if this eventually goes this way with
the process it's way too slow of a
process
in the process of business like what we
do what i cons the reason why we
invested into that technology three and
a half million dollars that we
put time into the last two years is to
eliminate steps so you can
accelerate a process if bitcoin
can accelerate multiple processes
for people's lives and find i think the
challenge they've had here's the
challenge with bitcoin
the typical bitcoin investor that's
obsessed about bitcoin
who understands it is it fair to say
that they have to be brighter than an
average individual when it comes down to
that they have to understand the
technology blockchain
you have to understand what's really
going on you can't sit there and explain
it to the average person
the average person is like what are you
talking about crypto well you got a mind
what the hell is mining well mining is
this and
you know the deeper you go people like
dude it's just too technical for me
versus a baseball card industry that's
blown up right now and they're selling
shares of
baseball cards here's this baseball card
they printed a hundred thousand of them
only 20 of them have got a psa 10. this
is one of the 20 that we have
it's worth this much for you the
market's paying 180 grand what do you
want to pay for it it's probably going
to be a 500 000
card in five years the math and the way
you explain a baseball card is what
very easy so somebody says okay cool
i'll buy the baseball card and i'll sit
on it because you look at it as what
you look at it as artwork you know i'm
gonna just buy it and i'm gonna sit on
that artwork
bitcoin if they if they learn how to
explain the benefits of it to different
types of people business owners
the average investor the average buyer
the day-to-day person the person that's
insecure about their money being an
automatic person
that's older that's worried about money
and this credit card you know this i
don't want to use my credit card online
if they learn to do better marketing
with that i think the upset on bitcoin
can be very high because the direction
we're going right now people don't trust
the government people don't trust
politicians people don't trust these
people they're writing money
like crazy they don't trust them so i
think i think
timing is on their side and if they do
it right this could be a very
interesting direction we go to the next
five or ten years
i just have a thought process and i'm
kind of tying everything we discussed
with tesla
with bitcoin so you know again with my
whole interviews everything i'm doing
i've interviewed a lot of people you
know when i do my man on the street
stuff
and i i actually went to a bitcoin
convention
and i interviewed hundreds and hundreds
of people
who have no investments whatsoever no
401k
plan no ira no roth ira no access to the
traditional stock market no s p 500
index fund
nothing nothing nothing nothing but they
got a bitcoin account
yeah that's very dangerous that is very
dangerous that's like saying oh are you
a stock market investor yeah where do
you invest
tesla that's it you just have one stock
tesla
yeah i'm riding with elon very dangerous
so diversification so i've learned this
just through
through my time just investing you know
you kind of have your
your your main entree for me that's an s
p
500 index fund cool i have a majority of
that but you also have little bonds you
have maybe have a little
gold maybe you have a little
cryptocurrency if you're a believer in
in in bitcoin and blockchain you know
rather than doing five ten percent maybe
you put
yeah i've got like i put five percent
you know like nothing crazy
yeah i put in you know
three years ago like 40 grand holy crap
yeah i mean so no it's gone up a little
bit by that
sixth out no no no no no no no this was
at like 15
50. okay good yeah so no it's gone up a
little bit but
never in a million years i put all my
money into bitcoin or
into any crypto or into tesla that's
ludicrous but that's the
that's what people are doing it's like
oh i'm investing in bitcoin let me give
you the flip side of it let me give you
the flip side of it let me give you the
flip side of it
as ludicrous as that is in the next
five ten years you're going to hear so
many people
that this thing if this thing goes to
half a million dollars there's going to
be so many accidental billionaires that
they're going to say
billion everyone's going to talk to them
like an expert mm-hmm but they did
exactly what you told them not to do
they did the put everything in so what
i'm trying to say they buy and hold long
term whatever they don't try to
get in and get out if somebody is
playing the i don't care i'm going for
every i want it all or i'm nobody that
that's a strategy some people are taking
they're banking on bitcoin helping them
become millionaires billionaires
that's what they're banking on i i don't
think it's a
most uh uh uh uh uh
least stressful strategy yeah but if
this thing goes in a direction it's
gonna go
it could end up being a very big victory
for those risk versus rewards exactly
exactly so if you enjoyed this little
short segment from the podcast that we
did here's another short segment to
watch or if you want to see the entire
podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye